so uh president joe biden had his
meeting with republicans at the white
house on monday night to talk about the
coveted relief bill
joe biden had proposed a 1.9 trillion
dollar package
republicans were allowed to express
to joe biden why they want a 618 billion
dollar package but it's now being made
abundantly clear that joe biden and
democrats
are hopefully ready to move ahead
without republicans that's what uh
joe biden's press secretary jen saki
said earlier this week at a white house
press briefing
it's what joe biden seems to be
communicating and i hope that it's time
to just go
and do it because at this point in time
i don't see the benefit to anybody
on in the democratic party and that
includes joe biden as well as democrats
in the house and senate
of waiting with the idea that maybe some
republicans might be okay with some kind
of completely
flaccid and pathetic uh compromise
between the 1.9 trillion and the 618
billion and at this point the
perspective should be
uh if republicans realize that
the 1.9 trillion dollar package and what
it contains
is popular even with some of their
constituents
it's republican voters who want the
stimulus package too
if some republicans realize that then
maybe they'll vote for it in the house
or vote for it in the senate if they
don't realize that or realize it but
don't care
and every single republican decides to
vote against the 1.9 trillion
coveted stimulus package let them do it
at their own
peril and what i mean by that is once
their names are on the record
as saying no i'm against
the coveted stimulus package that is
popular
even with many of my republican
constituents
well then it'll be up to republican
voters to decide whether they
want to re-elect those very same
republicans and my guess
is you will get some republicans to come
along with joe biden's plan because they
realize that many of their constituents
want it so joe biden has been widely
criticized for sitting down with
republicans on monday
night and not with democrats some hot
takes saying
this is a right-wing president he talks
to republicans but not democrats
i think that that is very far from what
is going on
i am pleased increasingly that joe biden
and democrats
aren't budging on the 1.9 trillion
dollar proposal
joe biden had no need to meet with
democrats because joe biden and
democrats
mostly are on the same page about the
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package
do the meeting with republicans because
joe biden said that he wanted unity he
said he wanted bipartisanship he said he
would work with republicans and he's
trying to
and that olive branch was this meeting
on monday night but it's time to stop
uh when joe biden said if we win these
georgia races two thousand dollar checks
go out immediately
that doesn't mean you negotiate with bad
faith actor republicans into march
and hopefully get checks out by the end
of march if not early april
enough time has gone by and if joe biden
and democrats don't move forward on the
1.9 trillion
put it at risk you know if republicans
really want to vote against it let him
do it
but if joe biden doesn't move forward
with this it is going to be a failure in
joe biden's column he was
very clear about what he would do and
what it would mean
to add senate control for democrats in
addition to joe biden taking the white
house from donald trump
and we will now see if they are going to
put their money where their mouths are
now i think that
the calculation to be made um
there's a couple of calculations here
when you think about this from a
political strategy
standpoint democrats by not budging on
1.9 trillion are doing a couple of
different things
number one i hope democrats and joe
biden realize
that if you meet somewhere in the middle
like imagine that democrats say okay you
know what
we want 1.9 trillion republicans want
618 billion
let's do 1.3 trillion or something like
that
a ton of republicans are still going to
vote against it
even though it will end up likely
passing and so republicans will end up
getting the benefit of it passing and
money getting to their constituents
while continuing to be able to virtue
signal about the debt
and the deficit and spending oh and what
not everybody deserves the money and all
of this sort of stuff
so the calculation i hope democrats are
making is
they know the plan is more popular with
the country
than the portion of people who voted for
joe biden in other words
this is a coveted stimulus package
that's popular with 60 65 70
of the country that's much more than the
share that voted for joe biden that
means there
are millions of republican voters that
like this plan
and they want it to pass if democrats
realize that
and they realize even if we negotiate
with republicans
many of them will still vote against it
let's just move forward we have the
ability to do this via budget
reconciliation
assuming all 50 democrats in the senate
are on board which
is still a bit of a question mark but is
likely
let's actually put these republican
senators in particular and members of
the house
in a position of having to vote against
something that their constituents want
let them vote no let them say it's bad
let them then have to go and explain
their votes to their constituents
i believe this is a political risk very
much worth taking for joe biden and
democrats
i think the meeting was a fine move for
joe biden
he's giving the republicans an
opportunity to show they actually
want to help the american people they
present a counter
offer that's so pathetic and pitiful
that it's humiliating and embarrassing
and now
put them in the position of actually
saying are you really going to vote for
nothing for your constituents
are you going to try to prevent any
money from going out
because this is the package so i'm fine
with the meeting
i'm fine with not budging i'm fine with
moving forward without republicans the
question now is can joe biden actually
get it done
if he can get it done his early approval
on covid and in general is going to
persist it's going to be buoyed for lack
of a better term
if joe biden fails to get this done
or something close to it like i think
even if joe biden did 600 billion in the
end
i think it would be considered a failure
he said two thousand dollar checks are
going out now we're already talking
about
adding 1400 to the 600 to make it a
total of 2 000. that's already a
concession that i don't like to see
if biden can't get this done and get it
done in the next 10 to 14 days
it is going to be the first major
failure of the biden administration
let's hope it doesn't happen i i remain
cautiously optimistic that
it will get done i like the way
democrats are just saying
it's 1.9 trillion that's what it is vote
no if you want republicans
i think many will end up voting for it
if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me
with a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video